bist du dazu in der lage fair news zu
erkennen ja klar anderen ja die glauben
mir nur was sie glauben wollen aber ich
bin rational und kritisch ist das so ich
meine jeder von uns hat ja so seine
lieblings informationsquellen denen er
vertraut meile und andere denen mir
nicht vertraut weil app gehört zu funk
aber sind wir doch mal ehrlich mehr als
vertrauen ist es ja auch nicht ich bin
keiner zeit jede schlagzeile jenen
artikel und jede quelle zu überprüfen
und wenn nachrichten fehler enthalten
sei es aus versehen oder vorsätzlich
fake news dann ist das ziemlich tückisch
weil wir aufgrund von nachrichten auch
unsere politischen meinungen bilden noch
hängt die politische einstellung eines
menschen zusammen mit seiner fähigkeit
fake news von real news zu unterscheiden
fallen zum beispiel menschenrechts der
politischen mitte er auf tägliche rein
oder sind es doch die linken ich bin mir
sicher jeder von euch hat auch schon
seine persönliche vermutung aber bei den
vermutungen müssen wir es gar nicht
belassen
denn das ganze wurde wissenschaftlich
untersucht und die ergebnisse dieser
studie sind sehr interessant und sie
werden euch nicht gefallen der begriff
fake news ist inzwischen ja so ein
bisschen überstrapaziert ist ein
richtiger politischer kampfbegriff ist
es geworden
ständig werden meldungen als fake news
bezeichnet obwohl sie eigentlich wahr
sind und auf der anderen seite werden
falsche meldungen als war verkauft was
dann wiederum echte fake news sind 2016
ist der begriff in aller munde so sehr
dass ich auch immer häufiger die
forschung damit beschäftigt hier zum
beispiel habe ich einen ziemlich neuen
preprint einer studie von zwei
britischen forschern ich teile das ganze
auf in zwei teile und ich kann mich kaum
entscheiden welcher teil besser ist teil
eins wer erkennt fake news das erste
experiment führten die forscher mit
amerikaner durch in amerika gibt es ja
nur zwei parteien das macht das ganze
forschungs technisch etwas einfacher als
zum beispiel in deutschland es gibt
einmal die democrats oder lippels links
der politischen mitte und die
republicans oder conservative rechts der
politischen mitte für diese studie
stoppte man sich rund 700
ricaner und erfasste mit hilfe eines
fragebogens ob sie eher libris oder eher
conservative war und zusätzlich zu
diesen beiden schubladen ordnete man die
leute auch entlang eines spektrums an
von volle kanne lippe bis volle kanne
conservative und eben auch alles
zwischen dritten bekam jeder teilnehmer
eine nachrichtenmeldung vorgelegt und
zwar einen screenshot einer tv
nachrichtensendung und einen kurzen
begleitenden text wohlgemerkt war aber
keiner dieser screenshots oder texte
echt nein doch die forscher hatten alles
erfunden sie haben vier verschiedene
fake news erstellt jeweils eine positive
meldung über obama bzw trampe nämlich
eine großzügige spende und jeweils der
negative meldung über obama bzw
trump nämlich die verwicklungen einen
wahl skandal jedem studienteilnehmer
wurde jetzt zufällig eine dieser vier
meldungen vorgelegt und sie sollten
beurteilen für wie glaubwürdig diese
erfundene meldung halten was meint ihr
wer es öfter reingefallen libris oder
conservative die antwort ist beide und
zwar gleichermaßen von den linken libris
wurden die obama und die anti tram story
als glaubwürdiger eingestuft als von den
rechten conservative man kann also sagen
die libris fielen bei diesen beiden
stories er auf die fake news herein doch
bei der anti obama und der pro tram
story war es genau andersrum wir
schenken die konservativste meldungen
mehr glauben als die repos und als ich
die forscher die teilnehmer nicht nur in
diesen zwei lagern sondern entlang des
spektrums an sahen wurde dieser effekt
nur größer je weiter man sich an das
jeweilige ende des spektrums bewegt man
kann also sagen je stärker die
politische überzeugung desto größer auch
die neigung fake news zu glauben die
diese überzeugung entspricht bei einem
zweiten experiment wurden 570 briten
befragt bei denen etwa die hälfte gegen
den br- exit gestimmt hatte die andere
hälfte für den brics it und doch diesen
teilnehmern wurden erfundene news
stories präsentiert entweder eine
meldung die positive folgen des black
seeds berichtete oder eine die negative
folgen des projekts berichtet service
ergebnis brakes it befürworter glaubt
und der positiven story mehr
der negativen dragsic gegner genau
andersrum das bedeutet jeder von uns
neigt dazu fake news zu glauben solange
sie in unser weltbild passen diese
befangenheit einseitigkeit und
voreingenommenheit nennt man ganz
generell die stärke meine politische
überzeugung desto größer mein base und
zwar egal ob ich ihr links oder rechts
eingestellt bin das ist schon ziemlich
interessant aber noch interessanter wird
es in teil 2 woher kommt unser bei
genauer gesagt wie hängt unser hang zum
weiß mit unserer persönlichkeit zusammen
und jetzt wird real in einem dritten
experiment rekrutierten die forscher 900
amerikaner wieder wurden ihre
politischen einstellungen erfasst und
wieder bekamen die leute erfundenen news
stories vorgelegt deren glaubwürdigkeit
sie beurteilen sollten dieses mal eine
positive story über trump und eine
negative story über trump nur dieses mal
erfassten die forscher zusätzlich auch
noch zwei persönlichkeitsmerkmale der
teilnehmer und zwar erstens kognitiver
stil kopfes bauch jeder von uns trifft
entscheidungen auf verschiedene art und
weise manche menschen sind eher rational
und holen sich gerne möglichst viele
informationen ein um eine entscheidung
zu treffen man sagt solche menschen
haben ein hohes kognition bedürfnis und
auf englisch need for cognition andere
menschen sind eher intuitiv und
entscheiden mehr aus dem bauch heraus
man sagt solche menschen haben ein hohes
vertrauen in ihre intuition oder auf
englisch faison intuition es gibt dazu
einen etablierten psychologischen frage
womit jemand erfassen kann
wie hoch das koalitions bedürfnis und
das vertrauen in die intuition sind dazu
muss man angeben wie stark bestimmte
aussagen auf 1 zu treffen wie zum
beispiel ich mag komplexe probleme oder
ob ich leuten vertrauen kann sagt mir
mein bauchgefühl wie wird sich jetzt
dieser kognitive stiert auf die
beurteilung von fitness aus nicht so wie
ihr denkt je größer das koalitions
bedürfnis desto größer war auch der 1
das heißt libris die sich als besonders
rational logisch einstuften schenken der
anti trump story besonders wie glauben
und der pro tom story besonders wenig
bei den conservative selbe geschichte
nur andersrum das heißt menschen die
sich selbst für rational logisch alten
denken nicht etwa differenzierter und
sachlicher sondern viel stärker in ihrem
eigenen weltbild und das auf beiden
seiten des politischen spektrums warum
ist das so ist man vielleicht gar nicht
so rational wie man selbst denkt eine
hypothese ist dass rationale menschen
zwar tatsächlich dazu neigen mehr infos
zu sammeln
diese infos aber meistens ihrem eigenen
weltbild entsprechen so dass ich dieses
weltbild immer mehr verstärkt eine
andere hypothese ist dass gerade
intelligente menschen besonders gut
darin sind aussagen die ihrem eigenen
weltbild widersprechen
wegzurationalisieren das finde ich
persönlich besonders beunruhigend denn
ich würde mich definitiv als sehr
rationalen mensch bezeichnen ich weiß
nicht wie es bei euch ist seid ihr eher
rational oder intuitiv stimmt hier oben
ab und was in eurer hypothesen für
dieses ergebnis schreibt es in die
kommentare
dafür neigten diejenigen mit besonders
großem vertrauen in die institutionen
dazu den erfundenen news stories
generell mehr glauben zu schenken und
dieser generelle trend war bei den
conservative etwas stärker ausgeprägt
als bei den lippen zaubert auf das geht
auch weiter das zweite
persönlichkeitsmerkmal dass die forscher
bei den teilnehmern erfassten war
connectiv nazis in kollektiver nazismus
also ein narzisst fühlt sich anderen
überlegen
ein kollektiver netz ist tut es nicht
unbedingt aber dafür glaubte dass die
gruppe der er angehört als kollektiv als
gruppe besser ist als andere gruppen
das heißt je mehr ein tramp supporter
davon überzeugt ist dass tom supporter
als gruppe trump gegnern überlegen sind
desto höher ist sein kollektiver
nazismus auf fragebögen kann man das
festhalten in dem man die leute aussagen
raiden lässt wie menschen mit meiner
politischen einstellungen die welt
regieren
dann wäre sie eine bessere welt der
denkt man ja leicht an klassismus oder
rassismus und assoziiert das vielleicht
er mit dem rechten politischen spektrum
aber diese studie zeigt dass andere
erstens politiker nazismus besteht auf
beiden seiten des politischen spektrums
und zweitens je größer der kollektive
narzissmus desto größer auch der weiß
dass auch auf beiden seiten des
politischen spektrums anders gesagt je
besser oder überlegener ich mein eigenes
weltbild finden desto eher neige ich
auch dazu fake news zu glauben die
diesem weltbild entsprechen
dieser effekt war jetzt bei den libdems
etwas stärker ausgeprägt als bei dem
konzert ist und ich weiß nicht wie es
euch geht aber bei kollektiven nazismus
muss ich leider sagen ja ich meine wie
oft sage ich sagen wie die freunde der
sonne sind die beste community der welt
oder wenn alle kommentarspalten so wäre
wie beim app dann wäre das internet ein
besserer ort es ist meine überzeugung
und es ist kollektive nazismus wie er im
buche steht
und ich glaube in diesem fall sogar
gepaart mit normalen nazismus sechs
fazit die antwort auf die frage erkennst
du fake news lautet wenn sie deinem
eigenen weltbild entsprechen
wahrscheinlich nicht jeder von uns hat
einen beiß der unsere wahrnehmung von
wahrheit und fake ganz stark beeinflusst
und psychologen sind sich einig man kann
diesen bei es nicht loswerden er gehört
zum menschsein dazu und wenn es diese
studie eines lehrt dann ist es der mut
denn egal welche politische haltungen
hat wir sind alle gleich drauf auch wenn
es sich anders anfühlt wir sind nicht so
schlau und die anderen auch nicht so
doof wie wir glauben wenn das doch mal
kein schöner grund ist sich auch mal
andere politische meinungen anzuhören
oder da fehlen nur noch diese schöne
worte des fantastischen bilder von
ubisoft
also freunde der sonne wir gegen euch
mit respekt hört euch gegenseitig zu wir
sehen uns diesen donnerstag bis dahin
bleibt sicher